this is a really really great Insight
from Alex homozy he says when I'm 50 I
trade everything I own to be 33 again
which means right now is more important
than all the wealth I'll ever accumulate
you'd give it all to live again today
that's a pretty heavy realization we
give up time to make money so that we
can finally have more time when we have
enough money we give up happiness to
achieve success so that we can have more
happiness when we achieve enough success
am I making money because I think that
making money is the thing that I need to
do in order to make myself happy but
when I actually assess the standard of
living that I need to be at what I
realize is that I'm already there or I'm
not going to be far off within the space
of the next five years so actually
driving myself into the ground or having
all of these different side hustles
which don't fire me up maybe I don't
need to do that now if they are things
that genuinely fire you up fantastic
lean into them as much as you want and
if the byproduct earn you a ton of money
then even better